Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
all about monica rambeau's powers on wandavision
the way they explained her in the mcu her origin
story and some of the changes from the comics and
what they're going to be doing with her in the
future of the mcu because she is super op in
the comics if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
i'll be doing videos for all the marvel disney
plus series this year falcon winter soldier is
going to be up after wandavision we got a couple
more episodes so we're almost at the finale but
big spoiler warning if you have not been watching
the wanda vision episodes because we'll be talking
about everything that's happened so far so during
episode 7 she goes through the hex barrier a third
time and that's what darcy said would scramble her
dna beyond recognition turn her into a completely
different person on a genetic level aka mutate her
everyone hearing the x-men theme playing softly in
the background but technically she's not a mutant
in the comics she's a mutate which is a slightly
different thing in order to be called a legit
mutant you have to be born that way so for example
wiccan and speed billy and tommy the twins were
born with their powers so they are legit mutants
in the mcu but she's crazy powerful in the comics
she's gone by several different code names based
on what they were doing with her during various
eras of the comics we'll get into that in a second
what's more important though is how they're
setting her up on the show and the way they're
using her powers on the show but as she pushes her
way through the hex barrier and it starts changing
her the way they visualize her origin story
is meant to be very 2001 space odyssey type of
sequence where you see her face shifting you see
reality warping around her all while she's being
bombarded by voices from the past like scenes from
the hospital episode 4 when she got snapped back
by the hulk you probably heard brie larson's voice
as captain marvel that was a scene directly from
the captain marvel movie where she was a little
girl talking to her about meeting her halfway to
outer space like she wanted to go help her out and
go on adventures with her which obviously now is
important because pretty soon she'll be able to
fly just like captain marvel and literally meet
her halfway up to outer space in the comics the
way she got her powers is she was bombarded with
energies from all kinds of different dimensions
by rocks and scientists who was trying to tap into
extra dimensional energy as an alternative power
source remember that's also where dr strange's
magic powers come from he pulls energy from other
dimensions to power his spells and enchantments
technically what he's doing though when he weaves
spells is allowing him to tap into those extra
dimensional energies you also notice that she's
phase shifting here she starts warping around
her you see the different versions of her from
different parts of her timeline when they start
overlapping you start to see versions of her comic
book costume there's a bit of an easter egg there
and obviously when she comes out and she's wearing
this outfit this is meant to be the modernized
version of her comic book outfit the black and
white one so they kind of try to give you as comic
bookie a version of her origin story as possible
at least a lot of easter eggs for that comic book
origin but when she emerges from the barrier
inside the hex her eyes glow blue with energy
and she starts seeing the entire electromagnetic
spectrum of the hex that's basically what this
is as she's peering around it's like neo seeing
the matrix seeing reality for what it really is
she's getting all this extra visual information
and one of her basic powers is a bit of a passive
power in the comics is the ability to analyze
and replicate all forms of energy there are a
couple qualifiers for that there are a couple
limitations on her abilities but when her eyes
are glowing blue like this is them showing you her
body analyzing the normal electromagnetic spectrum
then later when scarlet witch blasts her and she
soaks some of the energy damage then she puts her
in the telekinetic hold up in the air and drops
down doing the classic superhero landing she gives
off that blue energy discharge what's happening
is that first blast of red scarlet witch energy
her body was analyzing and adapting to it but
it's not instantaneous it takes her a minute
to be able to process and understand that kind of
information then when she drops down her body is
just instinctually absorbing and radiating some of
that kinetic energy of the impact with the ground
and scarlet witch's energy it's the exact same
concept with black panther's vibranium suit
he absorbs energy and then can later discharge it
as a burst or focus blast there aren't any real
limitations on what they can do with that sort of
energy it's just a matter of them being creative
with how they use it but monica's powers go way
beyond that but she's still learning how to use
them on the show right now like she's still fresh
out of the barrier like all marvel character arcs
they tend to evolve all the characters powers with
each new movie learn more creative uses for them
like thor's really good example thor during thor
ragnarok and avengers infinity war becoming a much
more powerful version of himself because he was
learning more about how his powers really worked
he was always that powerful it's just that he
never understood his powers up to that point
in ragnarok later during the post-credits scene we
get another similar type of moment following up on
that we're re-watching this a couple more times
in context i actually do think that she opens
the cellar door to activate hartness's basement
and sees the purple glowing vines of energy then
you zoom in enhance her eyes start glowing purple
and she gets caught by evan peters character it's
probably the same situation as before her body
is instinctively just detecting agatha hardness's
purple magical energy and she's in the process of
adapting to it so eventually if agatha harkness
tries to mess with her or mind controller it
probably won't work the way it worked on scarlet
witch because remember earlier in the episode when
scarlet witch walked down into the creepy basement
she just saw the normal looking vines no
energy radiating off of them the way monica did
that's because that's probably what the
basement looks like to just normal people
but monica is seeing it with her spectrum eyes
so to speak like her spectrum name in the comics
and seeing the power literally flowing through
them her eyes turn purple just because it's the
color of the energy she's detecting and they
want you to make that connection like oh purple
vines purple eyes detecting purple energy so
eventually just like in the comic she'll be able
to eventually defend herself much more readily
against agatha harkness's powers maybe even given
enough time give off blast like that as well that
gets into more of her complex powers in the comics
i'll talk about that in a second because it's
really cool she is a super op character in the
comics but on the show you probably noticed that
everybody has a different color for their powers
scarlet witch's powers are red even though agatha
hardness has the exact same magical abilities her
powers are purple vision has yellow powers because
of the mind stone tommy is kind of blurry running
with the quicksilver effects then billy's magical
energy even though his powers are the exact
same as scarlet witch's in probably act of the
harknesses his or bluish like monica rambeaus
the reason why they do that is just on a
practical level when they have their inevitable
battle royale in the finale full-blown wizard
battle you'll be able to follow the action a
little bit easier if everyone had the same color
of powers it'd just get a little confusing when it
started getting super crazy on screen but monica
is effectively now made of pure energy she can
turn into an energy form and travel at the speed
of light she becomes energy itself she doesn't
just give it off and blast or use it to fly that's
why she's so crazy op like at one point in the
comics she even turned into electromagnetic energy
and flew right through magneto's shield to beat
the crap out of him she even turned into gamma
energy and fought the she-hulk to a standstill
the limitation though on her powers is that yes
while she can replicate and control any form of
energy she has to be able to understand that form
of energy so if she encounters somebody else who's
wielding power from another dimension with some
brand new energy source she might get hurt during
their first fight but given enough time if she
were able to learn how that energy form worked she
could replicate it herself that's why if agatha
harkness blasted her with her purple magical
energy she would probably get hurt but if you gave
her enough time like we'll probably see during the
episodes she'd be able to defend herself much more
easily against it the other cool thing about that
is that it technically makes her stronger than
captain marvel because captain marvel in the mcu
got her powers from the space stone in infinity
stone but because of the way monica's powers work
she goes way beyond that she can replicate captain
marvel's power and use other powers as well she
can make herself invisible by bending light
around her body and use that same trick to also
make herself look like other people so it's kind
of like they're no limit to the abilities that she
has the way she can use her energy it's more about
her taking the time to learn the science of it all
and finding creative uses for her powers there was
even a scene in the comics that she had with blue
marvel during ultimates where they're nerding
out having that same thanos argument like who
could kill thanos faster like they had earlier
on the show and she actually gives blue marvel
a version of the thanos meme argument remember all
the ant-man thanos memes why doesn't he just fly
up his butt and then make himself big and explode
thanos from the inside monica's version of that
would be turning herself into pure energy and then
flying through thanos brain at the speed of light
faster than thanos would be able to react there's
also this really cool multiverse aspect to the
way her powers work too just explaining what is
happening when she's using her abilities so when
the way they explain magic in the mcu is basically
sorcerers pulling energy from other dimensions
to power their spells what happens when monica is
actually using her powers to blast someone or turn
into pure energy or travel at the speed of light
is that her mind is actually traveling to another
dimension and she's effectively remote piloting
her own physical body they're kind of doing the
same thing with scarlet witch on wandavision
developing her character explaining her powers
in a better way so oh you thought she was powerful
now once you understand how her powers really work
she's way more powerful than you ever thought that
she was that's what we're getting into with all
the house of m reality warping stuff is going on
inside the hex but getting into future wandavision
episodes the mcu captain marvel 2 and other marvel
projects that are coming up right now her powers
are still brand new she doesn't totally understand
how they work so she'll probably just be immune to
agatha harkness's mind control on the show and be
able to help scarlet witch escape and then during
their big final battle give off some huge power
blasts maybe fly a little bit we also have the
nick fury secret invasion series coming up next
year with all the scrolls and because the scrolls
and nick fury are so tied up in the captain marvel
story within the mcu and nick fury is so connected
to sword like he's on the sword space station
with all the squirrels during the spider-man
far from home post-credits scene we might also see
monica rambeau show up in cameo during the secret
invasion series and just talking about some of
the teasers for captain marvel 2 that we saw them
playing some track work in the earlier episodes
they kept repeating voice-over dialogue from brie
larson in the captain marvel movies speaking to
her when she was a little girl but when jimmy wu
and darcy are nerding out with her about who's
the most powerful person scarlet witch taking
down thanos what about captain marvel 2 like they
mentioned her name she gets really pissed off like
they're trying to imply there's some huge drama
between the two of them that they'll get into
during the sequel and now that she has powers too
they could actually duke it out a little bit like
monica rambeau could also adapt to and replicate
captain marvel's powers based on the way they
set it up during the episodes it sounds like the
drama between them might have something to do with
captain marvel just never coming back to planet
earth between the events of the first movie in
avengers end game like they had that scene during
endgame where rocket is clowning on her for not
being around to help out more she's like i'm busy
over here i have space problems i'm over increased
scroll space i'm too busy for your earth problems
their drama will probably be more complicated than
that but her absence while monica was growing up
at sword all those years is probably a big part of
it but explaining a little more of the history of
the character because she was the original female
captain marvel like she was a version of captain
marvel long before carol danvers what happened is
when they introduced her in the comics in the
early 80s she actually debuted during amazing
spider-man annual number 16. she debuted into
spider-man comic book of all places she was
introduced as monica rambeau and wound up getting
her powers and they were going to introduce her
as the next version of captain marvel because
they had killed off marvel the original version
of the character she's had a bunch of other comic
book names like spectrum photon the lady of light
pulsar sun goddess but i'm assuming the name that
they're going to go with in the mcu will either
be spectrum or photon most of the versions of her
comic book costume though look kind of like this
color scheme with the black and white they've
just been various versions of this just updated
throughout the years in the comics i'm assuming
when they do get to captain marvel 2 they will
give her a full-blown super suit and it'll just be
a shinier better version of her color scheme here
but hopefully that explains a little bit about
her origin story on the show in the mcu how that's
different from the comics and what her powers are
exactly and how they work everyone let me know in
the comments though where else do you want to see
her show up in the future the mcu projects just
beyond captain marvel 2 which other movies do you
want to see them put her in my full Wandavision
episode 8 video will post this friday but there'll
probably be a couple bonus videos before then
leave all your requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my Wandavision episode
8 trailer in that post credits scene and click
here for my full wandavision episode 7 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!